precious inheritance
we can't let that happen
[Applause]
left-wing mobs have torn down statues of
our
founders desecrated our memorials
and carried out a campaign of violence
and anarchy
far left demonstrators have chanted the
words
america was never great
the left has launched a vicious and
violent assault on law enforcement
the universal symbol of the rule of law
in america
these radicals have been aided and
abetted by
liberal politicians establishment
media and even large corporations
whether it is the mob on the street or
the canceled culture
in the boardroom the goal is the same
to silence dissent to scare you out of
speaking the truth and to bully
americans into abandoning
their values their heritage
and their very way of life
we are here today to declare that we
will never submit to tyranny
we will reclaim our history and our
country for citizens of every race
color religion and creed
the radicals burning american flags
want to burn down the principles
enshrined in our founding documents
including the bedrock principle of equal
justice under law in order
to radically transform america
they must first cause americans to lose
confidence
in who we are where we came from
and what we believe
as i said at mount rushmore
which they would love to rip down and
rip it down fast
that's never going to happen
two months ago the left-wing cultural
revolution is designed to overthrow the
american revolution
as many of you testify today the
left-wing rioting in mayhem
are the direct result of decades of
left-wing indoctrination
in our schools it's gone on far too long
our children are instructed from
propaganda tracks
like those of howard zinn that try to
make students ashamed of their own
history
the left has warped distorted
and defiled the american story
with deceptions falsehoods and lies
there is no better example than the new
york times
totally discredited 1619
project this project
rewrites american history to teach our
children
that we were founded on the principle of
oppression
not freedom nothing could be further
from the truth
america's founding set in motion the
unstoppable chain of events
that abolished slavery secured civil
rights
defeated communism and fascism
and built the most fair equal and
prosperous nation
in human history
the narratives about america being
pushed by the far left and being
chanted in the streets bear a striking
resemblance to the anti-american
propaganda
of our adversaries because both groups
want to see america
weakened derided
and totally diminished students in
our universities are inundated with
critical race theory
this is a marxist doctrine
holding that america is a wicked and
racist nation
that even young children are complicit
in oppression
and that our entire society must be
radically
transformed critical race theory is
being forced into our
children's schools it's being imposed
into
workplace trainings and it's being
deployed to rip apart
friends neighbors and families
a perfect example of critical race
theory
was recently published by the
smithsonian
institution this document alleged that
concepts such as hard work rational
thinking
and the nuclear family and belief in god
were not values that unite all americans
but were instead
aspects of whiteness
this is offensive and outrageous to
americans of every
ethnicity and it's especially harmful
to children of minority backgrounds who
should be
uplifted not disparaged
teaching this horrible doctrine to our
children
is a form of child abuse in the truest
sense
of those words for many years now
the radicals have mistaken americans
silence for
weakness but they're wrong
there is no more powerful force than a
parent's love for their children
and patriotic moms and dads are going to
demand that their children are no longer
fed hateful lies about this country
american parents are not going to accept
indoctrination in our schools cancel
culture in our work or the repression of
traditional faith culture
and values in the public square
not anymore
[Applause]
thank you
thank you thank you very much
we embrace the vision of martin luther
king where
children are not judged by the color of
their skin
but by the content of their character
the left is attempting to destroy that
beautiful vision and divide americans by
race
in the service of political power
by viewing every issue through the lens
of race they want to impose a new
segregation and we must not allow that
to happen critical race theory
the 1619 project and the crusade against
american history
is toxic propaganda
ideological poison that if
not removed will dissolve the civic
bonds that
tie us together will destroy our country
in the strongest manner possible
the only path to national unity is
through our shared identity
as americans that is why it is so urgent
that we
finally restore patriotic education to
our schools
under our leadership the national
endowment
for the humanities has awarded a grant
to support the development of a
pro-america curriculum that celebrates
the truth
about our nation's great history
we are joined by some of the respected
scholars
involved in this project including
professor
wilford mcclay
wilfred please thank you very much
thank you dr peter wood of the national
association of scholars
dr peter
[Applause]
thank you thank you and ted
rebarber thank you ted thank you very
much
today i'm also pleased to announce that
i will soon sign an executive order
establishing a national commission to
promote patriotic education
it will be called the 1776 commission
[Applause]
thank you it will encourage our
educators to teach our children about
the miracle of american history
and make plans to honor the 250th
anniversary
of our founding think of that 250
years recently i also signed an
executive order to establish the
national garden
of american heroes a vast outdoor
park that will feature the statues of
the greatest americans
who have ever lived today i'm announcing
a new name
for inclusion one of the 56
signers of the declaration of
independence was a patriot
from delaware
in july of 1776 the continental congress
was deadlocked during the debate over
independence
the delegation from delaware was divided
caesar rodney was called upon to break
the tie
even though he was suffering from
very advanced cancer he was
deathly ill rodney rode 80 miles through
the night
through a severe thunderstorm from
dover to philadelphia to cast his vote
for independence
for nearly a century a statue of one of
delaware's most beloved citizens stood
in rodney square right in the heart
of wilmington
but this past june caesar rodney statue
was ordered removed by the mayor and
local politicians
as part of a radical purge of america's
founding generation
today because of an order i signed
if you demolish a statue without
permission
you immediately get 10 years in prison
[Applause]
and there have been no statues
demolished
for the last four months incredibly
since the time i signed that act joe
biden said nothing
as to his home state's history
and the fact that it was dismantled
and dismembered any founding father
statue
was removed today america
will give this founding father this very
brave man
who was so horribly treated
the place of honor he deserves i'm
announcing that the statue of
caesar rodney will be added to the
national guard
of american heroes
from washington to lincoln from
jefferson to king
america has been home to some of the
most incredible people
who have ever lived with the help of
everyone here today
the legacy of 1776
will never be erased our heroes will
never be forgotten
our youth will be taught to love america
with all of their heart and all of their
soul
we will save this cherished inheritance
for our children
for their children and for every
generation to come
this is a very important day
thank you all once again for being here
now i will sign the constitution day
proclamation god bless you and god bless
america thank you very much
[Applause]
you
[Music]
you